so let me ask you it's not quite program
synthesis but uh the application of
these language models to generation
to program synthesis but generation of
programs so if you look at github open
pilot
which is based on openai's codex i don't
know if you got a chance to look at it
but it's
the system that's able to generate code
once you uh prompt it with
what is it
like the header of a function with some
comments and it seems to do an
incredibly good job
or
not a perfect job is very important but
an incredibly good job of generating
functions
what do you make of that are you is this
exciting or is this just a party trick a
demo
or is this revolutionary
i haven't worked with it yet so it's
difficult for me to judge it but i would
not be surprised if it turns out to be
revolutionary that's because the
majority of programming tasks that are
being done in the industry right now are
not creative
yeah people are writing code that other
people have written or they're putting
things together from code fragments that
others have had and a lot of the work
that programmers do in practice is to
figure out how to overcome the gaps in
their current knowledge and
the things that people have already done
how to copy and paste from stuck over
that's right and so of course we can
automate that yeah
to uh make it much faster to copy and
paste from stack overflow yes but it's
not just copying and pasting it's also
basically learning which parts you need
to modify
to make them fit together yeah
uh like literally sometimes as simple as
just changing the variable names
so it fits into the rest of your code
yes but this requires that you
understand the semantics of what you're
doing to some degree yeah
and you can automate some of those
things yes the the thing that makes
people nervous of course is that um
a little bit wrong in a program
can have a dramatic effect on the actual
final operation of that program so it's
one little error
which in in the space of language it
doesn't really matter but in the space
of programs can matter a lot yes but
this is already what is happening when
humans program code yeah this is so we
have a technology to deal with this
you